at Harvard why this is Kevin oir
building a brand in shark infested
waters it's a Harvard case about Mr
Wonderful I can't believe it it's
surreal of course I'm honored no
question about it the whole story is in
here the whole Mr Wonderful story
there's a lot to learn good bad and ugly
it's in the case now I'm going to teach
it you should conceptualize it first
time anybody can build their own network
so with that Kevin o
thank you very much all right let's have
a seat audience AI helps video creators
preest their videos what's the revenue
model you going to let them try this
first to prove it out we're the first
basketball shoe brand that creates and
innovates products collectively for
consumers are you willing to move to
North Dakota if you give me $100,000
I'll be there tomorrow the only gwing
concern I had was is there something I
don't
if you have employees you need to check
out the ERC program Chef wonderful why
Mr Wonderful because it's cash flow that
you don't have to pay back good to know
this guy's so smart and so handsome go
to wonder trust.com to see if you're
eligible